so how far is the glacier premier yes
we're going to start the video stroke
glacier which is the biggest glacier in
Norway bringing Aaron Justine to climb
but some climb on some ice see if they
will survive it I doubt it but see
you're all are very bright thank you my
mom used to rub me in books when I was
younger any very Clark sounds like a
very interesting childhood I can't even
explain what I'm saying right now and
you guys can't even see how freaking
amazing this looks because this is not
doing it justice this is the start of
our journey
you've got axes and knives and guns and
zombie apocalypse backpack
I know
it's almost time to hike this glacier
got my GoPro hoping it doesn't pull off
this helmet because if it does it's
going to be lost few guys ready
I'm legit stop now
really hard I have no idea you know to
expect
very
just made it up this is first a little
bit holy crap this is a lot harder than
I thought it's seriously really really
scary
pretty good going up let's collect
arctic circus monkey bud gonna lie I was
very scared look I'm gonna fall I'm
gonna fall let's not go down I'm
seriously just blown away wait you did
you really check me in I didn't check
you we don't know what's down there but
we don't have a choice because it's
getting late
I mean come on it before you love makes
it worse as I have no idea what they're
saying they only speak Norwegian when
it's actually really dangerous I know so
just write it down joseon's doing the
last descent it's actually really
dangerous because there's a straight
drop about 10 or 15 feet then it slides
out you can walk on it
between Aspen's head and the two lines
you see above it there's an extremely
deep crevasse the wall straight back
let's hit that go from one to the other
I've got a place
who are you Justine
man the whole wall shaking
okay
Thanks
Verdi's how's your leg it's crazy
it's but I had said crazy so many times
because I have nothing else to say to
describe it with this there's new no
work
it's getting dark so if we don't make it
back aren't on my glove you don't make
it back before dark
or you just hear that
it's minecraft sleeping music we need to
find cover sa P or the creepers we're
gonna get us you can't even see anything
I will sprained my ankle five times it
was it was sued you can still see the
glacier all the way over there I can't
really see you but how are you feeling
oh my god kill me I can't see anything
photos oh oh then I was pedaling back
from glacier hike and now it's time to
make dinner
absolutely makin what you cook up today
making a wise man